-I'm so happy to be here.
-So happy to see you in studio.
You've been so nice
to come on the show
through Zooms
and all that stuff.
-And where was that?
Was that hanging
on a screen here?
-It was a screen behind you.
Yeah.
And so that's where you were.
And weirdly enough, you were
in the building Zooming.
-Oh, yes.
-You just didn't want to come
into the studio to see me.
-No, no.
I mean, I live right here.
-Yeah. You --
Yeah, which --
-I'm in the apartment
right that way.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Are we too loud, or...?
-Oh, you're totally fine.
-Okay, good, yeah.
We have to talk
about your projects.
We don't really have to,
but I want to mention.
-Oh, quickly.
-Yes, you're on "Big Mouth"
on Netflix this Friday.
You're a voice
of one of the characters.
Congratulations on that.
And then, another announcement
came out
that I was very excited --
I didn't --
I should have congratulated you.
Sorry about that,
but congratulations.
You're gonna be one of
the voices in the new
"Super Mario Bros." movie.
-Yeah.
-The movie.
Movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's called a movie.
-it's called a movie.
Google it, and...
-Look it up.
-Look it up in the dictionary.
-Yeah.
-It's called a movie.
It's a movie.
How long have you lasted?
I don't know. Decades?
-Uh, look it up
in a thesaurus.
-Yeah.
-Another name for it is film.
-Movies.
-It's called movies.
-Yeah.
-Go to one.
-Be in one.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember encyclopedias?
-Yeah. Do you remember how,
like, how big they were
and how many you would have?
-Like a whole collection.
-Yeah. Like,
that's what you went to.
Like, "Well, we'll look it up."
-Yeah. Everyone would go,
"Yeah, we'll look it up."
Yeah.
Then "Microsoft Encarta."
-Yeah.
-You know, stuff like that.
-So we'll talk about
stuff like that when we get out
on the air.
-We're gonna talk about
encyclopedias and...
-Yeah, stuff like that.
Yeah, Microsoft Encarta.
You know,
maybe bring up "Prodigy."
You'll go,
"Do you remember Prodigy?"
And I'll say, "Yeah, I do."
Then you'll say,
"Oh, do you remember, like,
they used to have --
you had to dial in.
You have the phone dial in,
it went, "Cwk-ck-cwk."
That'll get a laugh.
-But should I do it
to the audience?
Don't you feel like it should be
like, "Do you guys remember?"
It should be more like that,
like, "Right?"
-Yeah, so you come out,
I sit here.
No, you sit here.
-I sit here.
-Yeah. And then you got to go,
"That sounds like
'Microsoft Encarta.'"
Do you guys remember the sound?
[ Cheering ]
-Yeah. And we'll cheer.
-That's a bit.
And you do that --
And you go out there
and do the "Prodigy" bit.
[ Both mumbling ]
-And then -- so, then,
I'm sort of surprised.
I go, "Whoa! No --
And you've been there?"
-Yes. Yeah.
-Oh!
And Greece is beautiful.
And...
-Yeah, we'll talk about Greece.
-Greece and the ocean.
-And then I'll go, "'Ey, like,
Sandy, I can't believe you."
-"Not that one."
-"Not that one.
"Don't be silly."
And I go, "Yeah, sorry.
Back to the projects."
-Yeah, back to the projects.
-And you're like,
"I had a good time
filming in Greece.
-Yeah, filming in Greece.
-"The director
is a good friend of mine..."
-"A good friend of mine, genius,
you know, wonderful."
-"We have lunch, we have --"
Talk about a project,
that "I never thought
I'd be one, but now I am."
-And then a funny story,
I guess.
"And so they order falafel,
and this guy looks at me."
And, you know...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and he goes,
"We're not open,"
"And now I feel awful."
[ Laughter ]
-I think --
I think that'll work.
-I ordered a falafel,
and now I feel awful.
Yeah. But you don't have
to do any of this stuff.
You know, it's old material.
I want you to come out
and be real.
-This is very much the real me.
And I like talking
about those things.
-How many different frames
of glasses do you own?
-I think like 10.
Maybe 10.
-Are you getting to, like,
an Elton John stage?
-I probably will.
-Right?
Like, he had a hundred different
frames of glasses.
-I don't know if they'll
be too, like, wild.
But I do want to change it up
a little bit.
-Would you ever wear red frames?
[ Laughter ]
-What do you think?
No, right? No.
-I don't think so, right?
-No.
-I think it's too much for you.
-It doesn't seem right.
It's too much.
-Black framed glasses, always.
-Yeah.
-But this is --
-These are greenish.
-They're olive, yeah.
Now I'm going to admit
something to you,
that you brought this up.
-Wow.
-And we did not plan this.
I was kind of, like,
tired of the glasses
I've been wearing,
and, today, I was like,
"I just need something else
for the show."
-You're kidding me.
-So these actually don't have
prescriptions in them.
[ Laughter ]
-This is insane.
-And I'm not kidding.
I'm not kidding.
-We did not plan this.
-This is insane.
Yeah. They have nothing.
-They have nothing.
-Fake glasses.
So I --
But you like wearing them?
-It just feels --
-Part of your --
-It feels nice. I like --
I like the feeling of it.
-I agree.
It fits you well.
-Yeah, I just --
I like the feeling on my --
-That's insane, dude.
-And so I stop at the store --
-You came on my show,
and you're wearing fake glasses.
-But I saw these 'cause --
-We're not even gonna air this.
I just think this
is fascinating.
-They're greenish gray,
which I like.
I like sort of gray-green.
-You're wearing a green shirt.
-Yeah, so I was just like,
"This might be exactly right."
For real --
I just saw these glasses,
was like, "This'll be nice."
-That's perfect for you.
Red frames I think is too much.
And you don't --
You don't do that.
It's like --
-No, no, no, no.
-You know, we were --
I was at dinner the other night,
and we're talking about
Norm McDonald jokes.
We missed Norm McDonald.
-Yeah.
-And I have -- Colin Quinn
told me about this great
Norm McDonald joke.
Do you want to hear it?
-Yeah.
-And so Norm McDonald goes,
"Yeah, I, uh --
I walked in
on my mother and father
having sex.
It was the most embarrassing
30 minutes of my life.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
It's a great joke.
That's a fantastic.
-I can't top it,
I can't top it.
-It's really funny.
It's a really funny joke.
-That's so good.
But Greece was beautiful.
It was -- the water --
[ Laughter ]
-Pretty clear.
-You can see through it.
You can see through the water.
-You can see through the water.
I've never seen through water.
I mean, obviously, it's water.
I've seen through, but when
you're in it, it's like --
-You look through the water
and think, "Okay.
I'm not gonna see through this,"
and they go,
"No, you're about
to see through it."
-And then you're like --
And I go,
"You know what? I actually
felt like a kid again."
-Aww.
And so we had another child.
-Aww!
-Awwwwwww...
...wwwwwww.
-...wwwwwww.
-The history --
the ancient history in Greece.
-Yeah.
You know what?
I chisel all the --
My job is I chisel
the genitalia off
statues in museums.
[ Laughter ]
What?
That's your job?
Yeah. Hey, you got to --
I got to pay the bills.
So I go to museums and...
-"Jimmy, that one, that one.
That one, Jimmy, that one."
-"Jimmy, that one
looks like it.
It's not one, but chisel it off
anyway."
-"Chisel, chisel, chisel."
-"It could be one."
-"We got these new ones.
Chisel, chisel, chisel.
And the nose on that one."
-"Just take the chisel -- Yes.
-"Why the nose?"
-"Well, it makes it look old.
Trust me -- you'll love it
when it's finished.
-Dd dd dd.
Bup bup.
-Yeah. "Oh, my god!
This is an old statue."
"Actually, no, I just got it
from Restoration Artwork.
-"Yeah, I had a chisel."
-"I had a chisel last week."
[ Both laugh ]
That's my job.
-That's your job?
-Wait. So, Fred, talk to me
about "Big Mouth."
So, you're in the show?
And who do you play?
You're Nick Kroll's dad.
-I'm his dad.
And his name is Elliot.
-It's fun to do.
-And it's based -- The voice --
This is for real.
I know we've been doing
a lot of bits.
You guys are
so patient and so nice.
But I did the voice to sound
like Henry Winkler.
-Really?
-You know, 'cause in interviews,
he's very -- he's very warm.
-Wow! That's an amazing
Henry Winkler impression.
That is exactly him.
-Oh, thanks.
-That is amazing.
-Thanks. Thank you.
-That actually sounds
exactly like --
-You know what I mean, right?
-Yeah.
-Because he's sincere
and he talks about --
You can hear a little bit
of New York in there,
a little bit.
-Yes, a little bit.
Oh, my gosh.
-And so --
-Dude, have you ever
done this for Henry Winkler?
-No. I didn't think about
doing it,
but only for the voice for this.
-He's going to freak out.
This is him.
-Wow. That's so nice of you.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Fred in
the new season of "Big Mouth."
Take a look at this.
-Okay, I get it. I've heard you.
You don't love me anymore.
You want a divorce?
That's fine.
All I ask is
100% custody of you.
-I don't want a divorce, Elliot.
I just want to have
a real conversation
about our daughter having sex.
-Oh, you want a
real conversation, do you?
-Yes, I do.
-Well, here's what I think.
Leah is ready to have sex
when Leah says
she's ready to have sex,
because we made Leah
ready to have sex
when Leah's ready to have sex.
-I know, but you need to let me
have my feelings about it!
-I'm yelling, but I'm actually
very sorry about that.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
"I'm yelling, but..."
Fred, before --
[ Applause ]
"Big Mouth," Fred Armisen.
Before you go --
Last time, I asked you --
I begged you to do
some impressions, and you did.
And you were very nice.
And now I'm asking you again
to do another thing.
I don't know why I'm asking
you to work.
-Here's what we're gonna do.
-Okay.
-This is something
I'd like to try.
-All right. This is what
I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, what I want to do is,
I want to give examples
of strumming styles.
[ Guitar strums ]
But this is going to be, like,
strumming styles of punk
and alternative music
from 1970 to 2000.
This is a sort of
truncated version of, like,
how people played the guitar.
So we'll start with 1970,
and there were fewer, like,
solos and stuff like that.
It was a little more rh--
They had more, like, rhythm
to it and percussion.
So, like, something like
Velvet Underground
was kind of like...
♪ Going down the boulevard
with the flower ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
That kind of thing, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Boulevard.
-So then like --
So then like mid-'70s,
there was stuff like the Ramones
and the stuff at CBGB's,
very driving like...
♪ I just want to watch TV ♪
♪ My baby's giving me
a lobotomy ♪
[ Both singing gibberish ]
That kind of thing.
-Yeah.
-But then in --
-Going down the boulevard
with a flower.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, in England, like
1977, same kind of thing,
but, like, a little more angular
and sort of like...
♪ Don't go to the ambulance ♪
♪ Don't go to the ambulance,
don't go to the ambulance ♪
♪ -Don't run on ♪
Yeah, love that.
-Yeah, that kind of thing.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Then like 1980, like post-punk,
they sort of, like, didn't do
chords that much.
It was a little bit more like...
♪ I am a neon light ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I am a neon light ♪
♪ I am the neon light ♪
Yeah, that's great. Love that.
-Then early '80s, there was like
a sort of like country music
feel to, like, punk.
It was kind of like...
[ Singing indistinctly ]
Yeah, that kind of thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then there was like
a sort of mid-'80s, late '80s,
like Sonic Youth would do this
thing where, like, the chords
would be a little discordant.
So it'd be like...
♪ Candlelight ♪
♪ On a booth ♪
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. That's exactly right. Yeah.
I remember that.
-And then, do you remember
the early '90s,
like a little ska thing
happening?
And very playful,
kind of like...
-Yep.
♪ -Your mom and dad were
the best you ever had ♪
[ Both singing gibberish ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-That kind of thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then Seattle,
Pacific Northwest, you know,
they did a lot of octaves,
like...
Kind of like half time, like...
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-Then like, Sleater-Kinney would
be, like, more single notes.
♪ Don't go so slow ♪
♪ Out of control ♪
-Yeah, that's right. Love that.
-And then like 2000,
things got very melodic,
a lot of clear chords, you know.
Like crooning, a lot of,
like, happy singing.
You know, like...
♪ Come out with me again ♪
♪ I'd like to take you to
the stratosphere ♪
Yeah, you know?
[ Both singing indistinctly ]
Kind of like Strokes kind of.
-Yeah, yeah, love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Fred Armisen, everybody!
Season five of "Big Mouth"
premieres Friday on Netflix.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Lucy Dacus.
Stick around, everybody.
♪♪